how important is an actor's real as a
tool to help someone bookwork you real
is huge and your real should be quick
and a trend that I've noticed even over
the five years that I've been here is
shorter clips and clips that are well
labeled and not not just one long real
but short clips Kieran speaks French in
blah blah blah Karen in rom-com blah
blah blah you know split those things up
on YouTube in addition to your physical
real have lots of very short clips a
minute or less that people can look at
also have some longer scenes but there's
a at least of my experience there a lot
of people who don't want to sit through
an entire scene they don't want to take
that journey with you because they're in
the middle of their day they just want
to know what you look like on camera so
give them that opportunity in very short
clips and then of the sort of actors
tools the real the resume the IMDB page
the agent or the manager if someone had
to pick just one as the most crucial
which would it be you can't pick just
one I mean if it's your iud page it has
to be pimped out with your real because
you want your real on your any actor who
does not have a demo reel uploaded inbd
it's a part of the package if you don't
have your demo reel right there you're
crazy that's so I would say if you can't
do anything else have an inbd page and a
demo reel but you know that's not even
that's not even a false answer
everything you've mentioned is going to
be needed eventually but if you have to
have something to start with get the IBD
page up get the pictures up and get your
real up
you